that is until our next AI tool
superchargers D5 high in a world where
AI is inching closer to reshaping how we
design Our Living Spaces let's continue
our journey by unlocking the potential
of photoshop's generate tool think of it
as your architectural genus but without
the limitations of just three wishes
it's here to fulfill your endless design
dreams you remember the story of Aladdin
right he discovers a magical lamb home
to a genie ready to Grant his every wish
well photoshop's generade tool is a bit
like that Genie except you're not
confined to just three wishes you can
conjure up an infinite number of Design
Concepts and just like Aladdin all you
need to do is rub that metaphorical lamp
in our case that means upload a photo
and provide a text prompt ridiculously
simple